WE CAN'T BEAT HIM OTHERWISE.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW, DELIGHTED HE'S
WITH US, MATT WHITAKER, FORMER
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ACCORDING TO CBS, THERE ARE TWO
PARTS OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
ONE PART CONCERNS THE EFFORTS TO
SWAPOUT ELECTORS, WON BY BIDEN
AND SEVERAL BATTLEGROUNDS.
ANOTHER IS EXAMINING THE ACTIONS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6TH WHEN THE
SUPPORTERS OVERRAN THE CAPITAL.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY EVIDENCE,
MATT, THAT TRUMP COULD BE IN ANY
TYPE OF LEGAL JEOPARDY, CRIMINAL
JEOPARDY UNDER THESE TWO BROAD
UNDERSTANDINGS OF WHERE THIS
INVESTIGATION IS GOING?
>> YEAH, I HAVE NOT.
GLAD TO BE WITH YOU.
YOUR INTRODUCTION IN THE
MONOLOGUE WAS SPOT ON.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE LEFT IS
TRYING TO DO HERE.
I WAS SHOCKED BY WHAT
MERRICK GARLAND SAID,
ESSENTIALLY LEAKS WERE GIVEN TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THE DAY
BEFORE HIS INTERVIEW AND INSTEAD
OF SAYING I CAN'T CONFIRM OR
DENY THE EXISTENCE OF AN
INVESTIGATION OR I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT ONGOING INVESTIGATIONS, HE
GAVE THE LEFT EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE DEMANDING FROM HIM, WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL HE PRETTY MUCH
CONFIRMED DONALD TRUMP IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND WE SHOULD
REJOICE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK, AND IT'S
JUST REALLY SAD TO SEE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BE TAKEN
TO THIS LEVEL OF POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
YOU KNOW, THEY DID IT IN '16
WITH THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
AND CONGRESS TOOK OVER WITH THE
TWO IMPEACHMENTS.
NOW THEY'RE WORKING TOGETHER AND
COLLUDING WITH CONGRESS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO TRY AND
FINALLY COME UP WITH SOME WAY SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO OPPOSE
HIM IN '24 IF HE DECIDES TO RUN.
>> Laura: OBAMA'S FORMER
SOLICITOR GENERAL, MATT, HAD AN
INTERESTING READ ON GARLAND.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF GUY YOU
WANT RUNNING THE PROSECUTION,
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS NOT
BLOODTHIRSTY, WHO IS CAUTIOUS,
WHO IS INCREDIBLY RESPECTED BOTH
BY REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS,
APPROACHING IT LIKE THE WAY A
TRUE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
PROSECUTOR WOULD IN THE MOST
SOBER, CAREFUL WAY POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: FASCINATING.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY SET
ABOUT ROBERT MUELLER, IS IT NOT?
>> YEAH, IT IS.
AND I MEAN, HE JUST PRETTY MUCH
NEEDS TO PUT ON A RED NOSE
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE
IS.
WHAT HE IS SAYING AND WHAT HE'S
NOT SAYING IF THAT ACTUALLY
MERRICK GARLAND IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST PARTISAN PEOPLE THAT
COULD HAVE POSSIBLY BEEN PICKED
FOR THAT JOB BECAUSE WERE MEMBER
THE REPUBLICANS ARE THE ONE THAT
HELD BACK HIS SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION.
AND I GUARANTEE YOU THAT IN HIS
MIND HE WANTS TO PAY BACK THE
REPUBLICANS LIKE CHUCK GRASSLEY
AND OTHERS THAT DIDN'T ALLOW HIM
TO SIT ON THE MIGHTY
SUPREME COURT, AND SO HE IS A
COMPLETE LEFTIST.
EVERYTHING HE SAID IS IN SUPPORT
AND ADMIRATION OF, YOU KNOW,
MARXIST AND LEFT-WING IDEOLOGY,
AND I WOULDN'T, YOU KNOW,
BELIEVE A SINGLE WORD HE SAYS
WHEN IT COMES TO VOUCHING FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE MERRICK GARLAND.
>> Laura: A FRIEND OF MINE WHO
IS NOT A BIG TRUMP FAN TEXTED ME
TODAY SAYING BASICALLY ANNOYED
ABOUT TRUMP NOT TELLING PEOPLE
TO COME OUT OF THE CAPITAL
SOONER, BUT THE IDEA THAT THIS
RISES TO CRIMINAL INTENT TO TRY
TO OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT IS
JUST -- I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE SHE
SAID LAUGHABLE.
DONALD TRUMP JR. WAS AGAINST THE
PLAN, BUT THE PRESIDENT WAS FOR
SOME KIND OF PLAN WHICH HAS NO
SPECIFICS.
THE WHOLE THING IS JUST -- IT'S
LIKE LA-LA LAND.
>> IT IS.
AGAIN, THEY ARE LOOKING FOR ANY
SET OF FACTS THAT THEY CAN --
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, THE EXISTENCE
OF AN INVESTIGATION IS BAD
ENOUGH IF YOU'RE A POLITICAL
CANDIDATE.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO.
OBVIOUSLY THEY HOPE FOR A
PROSECUTION, BUT ULTIMATELY, YOU
KNOW, DONALD TRUMP, LIKE HE HAS
SINCE HE CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR, HAS FOUGHT THROUGH
ALL OF THESE NONSENSICAL
ATTACKS, AND LIKE HE OFTEN SAYS,
THEY ARE NOT AFTER HIM, THEY ARE
AFTER THE PEOPLE THAT HE
REPRESENTS AND, YOU KNOW, STANDS
IN FRONT OF.
SO I'M GLAD THAT HE'S WILLING TO
TAKE UP THIS FIGHT.
HE'S RIGHT, HE COULD WALK AWAY
AND ALL THIS WOULD GO AWAY, BUT
HE'S NOT GOING TO.
>> Laura: WELCOME A BUSINESS
INSIDER POINTED OUT THAT TRUMP
IN HIS TWEETS, MADE A BIG DEAL
ABOUT THIS, AVOIDING THE PHRASE
"THE ELECTION IS OVER" AND HIS
TWEETS WERE HE ACCUSED THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF NOT HAVING
ENCOURAGED TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION, THEY ARE SAYING
THAT THESE EXAMPLES SUGGEST A
CERTAIN KIND OF INTENTIONALITY
FOR A PARTICULAR OUTCOME.
THAT'S ROBERT WEISSBERG FROM
STANFORD.
IS A TWEET A PHRASE NOT USED IN
A TWEET, THAT'S NOW INTENT TO
COMMIT A CRIME?
I MUST'VE GONE TO A DIFFERENT
LAW SCHOOL.
I KNOW STANFORD IS A FANTASTIC
LAW SCHOOL, BUT I MUST HAVE
MISSED THAT IN LAW SCHOOL.
>> I MISSED IT AS WELL.
AND TO ME IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
LEFT, FOR AFTER 2016 AND THE
ELECTION, THEY SAID HOW
DONALD TRUMP WAS ILLEGITIMATE,
HOW HE KNEW HE WAS ILLEGITIMATE.
THIS WENT ON FOR IT -- HE IN
FACT -- THE PRESIDENT SENT OUT
TROOPS THAT SAID FOR 10 MINUTES
SHOW THESE CLIPS AND ONE THAT
SHE WAS ON THE OTHER FOOT, THEY
IMMEDIATELY DO THESE KIND OF
THINGS, SUGGEST THAT SOMEHOW NOT
SAYING THE RIGHT WORDS IS
EVIDENCE, THE MENS REA FOR
CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT SEDITIOUS
TREASON.
I MEAN, IT'S -- IT'S -- IT'S
NUTS AND IT'S TOO BAD WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS BUT I THINK
PEOPLE --
>> Laura: THEY SHOULD ALL
RESIGN.
>> YEAH.
THEY NEED TO KNOW THE